the farming episode of faux FOP is
classified em a it contains some coarse
language some nudity drug references a
sex scene time travel terrible Batman
impersonations at Charlie claussen
pronounced Clausen shaped hole and mild
coarse language foaf up advisors that
the program is not suitable for persons
under the age of 15 and minors must be
accompanied by an adult guardian or
priest this is John deke speaking
everyone relax this is time [ __ ]
ironically i'm not running
welcome to photobomb will anderson and
returning guest Charlie course and the
most frequent guest Charlie Coulson I
guess Charlie Clawson number one as he
is known although it's been a very long
while since we've sat down to do one of
those she'll so is that right shall I oh
I just looked up the last time i texted
you on that number and it was July okay
that's how long ago well yeah all right
so it's been a while what's been going
on type Anthony nothing nothing at all I
hear you blowing up on internet we
wanted to talk about that let's just
start with that let's because we won't
get to it otherwise what's going on with
you in the internet I always like a you
in the internet story so we had a
shooting did you know we have the guns
are legal here in America I mean today
if you had one today you made probably
oh I'm sure we have a problem I mean I
have a look at the news i'm sure there's
been a shooting a taste one today
imagine yep but it planned a planned
parenthood yes so in their minds an
abortion clinic an abortion in our in
our minds in the normal person's minds
all things women's health are taking
care of including pap smears and all
sorts of things that women need done
come in get a pet sorry John at sell
your babies live up there they save
lives from cancer and things like they
detect what they are all i care clinic
yeah but I their minds is I put a baby a
baby place yeah a bit place where the
babies go to die data hot his eye he's
good buddy hot cuz I'll and said two
months ago those fake videos came out
were you here for the fake videos okay
so one of the people running for
Republican president Carly Fiorina who
used to run HP who ran HP into the
ground who took a company of viable
exciting old-school company and turned
into garbage she's not running for
president right enough America right
oxygen I can do that to the hotel I know
I could ruin so many companies so fast
and then I could be president right so
she really wants to be President and
it's not going to happen but it's cute
people who've heard my podcast with
Gareth Reynolds will know that I once
interview to Carly Fiorina know
oh you did uh yeah at this conference
for an hour I did an hour one-on-one
with carly was she nice I mean she was
prim and proper she was brilliant like
you know yes he seems she didn't she
wasn't out for my comedy high jinks
right no don't seem like she'd like
comedy no no maybe the honeymooners she
might enjoy that right so yeah so anyway
she so tell me about her and the videos
so she does she's speaking in the debate
and she says you know I've seen these
videos of babies being killed viable
children being aborted then killed on
the table right and that kind of stuff
now they're Planned Parenthood videos
and and then afterwards of course
everyone's like hey where'd those videos
we haven't heard of these Ryan she's
like well I've seen it yeah and they're
like okay so where are they I've seen
them it's like the answer it's like
she's she's on the dock web all the time
yeah so she down there in tour when I
was getting into this like when I was
buying MDMA like on in silk road I saw
those videos I got my MDMA yeah I put
out a contract on a guy's life and I saw
these videos videos so of course they it
people track it down and they go right
this isn't real it's not planned
parenthood it's clearly some some woman
who's a doctor went through and said
this is why this wouldn't none of this
stuff can happen in America because it's
insanely against regulations they're
using different instruments it just
broke down why it's not even American
it's probably some some place that
doesn't have regulations in another part
of the world so and then also the baby
clearly wasn't aborted it was a
miscarriage right and you could tell
that because of whatever you can see
that has come out also and other things
so it's false but the far right takes it
as we've got to shut down Planned
Parenthood the Republican Congressmen
and start trying to shut down Planned
Parenthood they start having they start
having protests that's out of all the
Planned Parenthood's which are always
under protest in area but they peek and
outside they're yelling no more baby
parts that's a chance no more basic
parts no more baby parts so last this
weekend a guy goes in and shoots up a
plan paranoid
when I can shows a cop and 22 you know
yeah one guy in the parking lot and
someone else just as he's just because
he's probably life well it's what jesus
would write want just gave three people
very late term abortions right well look
like he killed a pastor well which Jesus
would have wanted right seek Jesus was
on him straight to heaven if there's a
cost roughly gave him a fast track if
the place he wanted exactly he wants to
be there so foster pasa Jesus got him
there right and he killed in Iraq war
vet which is okay well that's on
surviving the war but guess what being
in front of 7-11 and the plant pano is
gonna be worse I mean you wouldn't want
to go to Iraq and be killed by one of
their religious fanatics thank you when
you can be killed by an American
religious fanatic back honey he's not a
fanatic he's and misunderstood oh sorry
so I go and I immediately type into
twitter because I'm making a couple of
points here Wow I type my tweet was
another Christian terrorist is shooting
up an abortion clinic moderate
Christians do something about your
religious extremists right what I went
motor Christians speak Arabic but at
this point let me also say this nobody
knows who the guy is right we don't know
that he's a Christian but we can guess
because usually Buddhist or atheists
don't shoot at Planned Parenthood they
might cheat up something else right in
the same way as people speculated pretty
much straight off to Paris hell that she
had gone that was kind of the point I
was making is it whenever there's a
shooting everyone always goes o Muslim
terrorists and this is a parody so I was
making that point of likely be any
conclusions and also the point of why
don't you reel in your Muslims which is
the most insane [ __ ] argument that
anyone's ever [ __ ] created around
these people like well it's like the
fight what like some guy living in his
house in Michigan who's Muslim is
supposed to [ __ ] real in the crazies
he can't do it any more than I can right
right I mean it's like it's like
climbing a soul for Cosby I mean what a
new comedians real in your Cosby right I
mean nobody called on me to speak out
maybe when the Cosby think I met ya the
people just assumed that I was anti
drugging and raping people but I'd like
the only record as a mainstream comedian
super against the dragging and ripping
of people like I also condemn oh so and
I just thought I'd be one of those
tweets that would get like 20 retweets
and show a couple people go that's a
that's a funny look what you did you
took it was something funny it's just uh
it's just a twist making a point yep a
juxtaposition a comic juxtapositions you
don't know how many retweets have gotten
hey I'd like to know how many how many
reckon an average is if you just write
like a comedy tweet not not a I'm not an
angry or a sports eat we but you know
you write something as like a joker
point like that ordinarily what were you
saying 15 100 sure that seems like an
amount yeah that seems like the amount
of people who'd like something that's
like you know okay what about this one
there it has gotten 9700 51 retweets and
nine thousand and eight hundred twenty
two favorites hang on give me those
stats again 9750 one retweets and 9822
favorites right well that there's more
favorites in there are we there are cuz
some people didn't want to some people
are like hey I said what were you saying
and I want you to know that but I don't
want to get in there I also don't want
to make the people you're about to
explain ah because I didn't not like
I've never had I've had tweets go big
but I've never won't go this big but
certainly not is this big that's about
about it's a tweet that can be
completely misconstrued number one of em
not making like I'm trying to make an
ironic point here with this tweet which
is don't do this to Muslims but the
other point I'm making is extremist ur
everywhere absolutely right that it's
extremism that is the [ __ ] other than
the particular thinking about extremism
and I could sit here if so I want to
argue with me and have a debate about
whether or not Muslims are more
extremist I could sit here and probably
have a debate with you for a couple of
hours as to why that's [ __ ] that
extremists are extremists right right
right I've been percentage wise if you
look at the do what is they 1.6 billion
Muslims in the world and you know
there's 30,000 people india shore
whatever yeah like I mean percentage
wise I mean that you know it's nothing
that she kills ninety-nine point nine
percent of germs if you want to go
through the tweets of people who support
this and find them it's about the same
number right cuz there's a lot of people
tweeting how good this guy is I got you
type a plant pair all right to waiting
to you or 20 again just tweeting in
general like but I go so first of all
now America's just crazy like we're like
it's we've gone so far batshit crazy
when I was watching the debates I was
struck by so I'm watching all the
Republican debates and the first ones
are like I'm I think ones on NBC in ones
on CNN but they like I said and what is
5 i'll try to bring it all together but
talk us through help the debates
actually work because women out oh my
god we have like a sense of this but
because i spent a lot of the time this
happened in australia the only get that
australian perspective on what's going
on in America where everyone's like
Jesus what the [ __ ] is happening right
yeah you get the what because that's all
you really should get it get the crib
notes because it's crazy when you get
into it so they have no viable candidate
usually now what yet why is that though
why they haven't because at the moment
it seems to me like I get the fact that
all the crazy people are winning yeah
but why is in no one that eventually
everyone's kind of like up it will
settle on this guy well that goes back
to the Tea Party so they they won they
won all in 2010 they want all the state
houses so they won most of the the
relatives or most of the state elections
that means they can carve up all of the
voting districts call it's called
gerrymandering after a guy named
gerrymander first thought of this and
like the 1800s oh really any idea is to
carve it up so you can get the votes you
want so they basically went in and they
and they get these crazy Rorschach I'd
like to think your Apes I like the thing
there was a vote for what they call it
and he even rigged that you know what
Jerry you have now they're so you have
manded this one hundred percent this is
yours gerrymandering so I mean there are
I mean this some of the district's look
insane like I but you know it was like
chili in Australia square in Australia
they used to have like gerrymandering
like in particular States in particular
had oh yeah you know and essentially
it's our Lord Dallas as it should be
because the people in charge shouldn't
be able to come up with no it's batshit
this is this we're now dealing with the
results okay yeah so
so they go and do that 2010 then they
then that's why our Congress is so full
of Republicans right now it's not
because they're more popular it's
because of the gerrymandering and
they've got and they created these
insane white districts where a guy will
get voted in like ninety-eight percent
of to like it's just batch occurs but
what they didn't know when they were
doing that is they were creating a
monster because you need you do need you
have to be deluded a little bit or else
it's [ __ ] Hitler people right right
it's people who have one mindset and and
they just talk to themselves and they
don't hear anything else and so that's
the tea party that's where the Tea Party
came from that's where that the
congressional candidates came from an
and the Republicans sort of encouraged
the Tea Party to be a thing and they
pushed it and they made this sort of
white older crowd very riled up and then
they brought them in and then they got a
bunch of elected to Congress and what
they assumed would happen is that they
would walk in and flip open the doors
and go look at all the pots of gold we
can make money if we all play ball and
they opened up the doors and they said
look at all the money and the right
winning tea party guys would get that
out of my [ __ ] face I don't want that
and they were like what do we just do so
they created they created their own
Frankenstein so now they have this
insane batshit no no compromise wing of
the party and it's eating the Republican
Party and the old-school Republicans
don't know what to do about it they're
just getting slaughtered so now we're
seeing now we're several years down the
road rights coming up in 2016 more and
more moderate Republicans who are viable
candidates have been going away they're
just getting beaten out by these crazy
guys in the primaries and they have now
no one who was just a normal guy who can
win and on top of that are our Supreme
Court said hey everybody all money can
be spent spend whatever you want and so
now that meant that meant the parties
couldn't control the purse strings and I
have guys like Trump Trump as a result
of the parties is no longer having
control over who they want to sort of
push to be President otherwise you'd
have one of the smaller
so anyway that's what we have so we have
16 candidates on the Republican side all
of whom are just completely batshit is
like 16 and 0 terrible I'll tear up like
you can't even like you kid if any of
these guys were running 20 years ago
they would just not even have it just
like a slight chance like they're just
batshit insane and they live in another
world where the news cuz when i said on
watch that first debate on fox i was
like oh they don't live in our world
like they did a Benghazi commercial for
Michael Bay made a Benghazi movie I
think it's michael bay or it's uh what's
the other guy the guy do the
transformers that's Michael Bay what was
the other one who's the guy who created
Michael Bay he's the father of Bay I
don't know the original Jerry
Bruckheimer Oh Jerry Brown that's the
father of a did you not know that yeah
one day at Fox they went into the studio
and and Michael Bruckheimer was laying
on the floor pan Jerry Jerry me
projector Jeremy bright Jeremy derriere
come on Jay Bruckheimer was laying on
the floor panting and they say what are
we doing he just gave me some hot water
and towels and slowly for the rest of
the day he birthed a bye I came right
out of his a man vagina right and there
was a little baby and it when Michael
baby about a tiny Michael Bay I mean
that is not planned parenthood it is not
planted at all is unplanned parachuter
that day very uh I tell you what the
birth video I looked amazing that five
shots I've choppers so many I mean but
in our crashes I didn't the whole deal
will they immediately threw him on the
back of a truck or they got him on the
highway I think
and the helicopters came in from from
Warner Brothers Studios they're trying
to shoot at him oh yeah it was really
tough is really good but that baby came
out that baby like I said I do the
debate on Fox now Fox is you know
obviously the you know the the
Republican what so what's going on so we
know what are you dealing with the
Christ we know why must know right that
I don't I don't actually Fox this to me
is the big unknown because i think i'm
not sure if i cant want Trump to win
folks they are they are trying to talk a
little bit of you know they don't want
Trump to win and they are now starting
to talk a little bit of reason but
they're so in over their heads like they
have to keep their audience right and
while there is to keep their audiences
to keep telling you what they want to
hear but at the same time that's just
taking them down this crazy [ __ ]
wormhole of just insanity and none of
its true like you watch their networking
you know this this is like being on
another planet like it used to be read
watch Fox you just hear the opposing
view of something you heard on the other
network now you hear something you know
this is another world like you're not
even in our world the Benghazi thing has
been going on for three years right we
had four we had four State Department
people killed and it's been on for four
years they've had they spent over almost
five million dollars on investigations
Congress spent eighty six thousand
dollars on an investigation of Katrina
86,000 86,000 hang on what I'm
photocopying the report like you don't
you don't spend that much money on any
of these things because it doesn't cost
that much that people come in and talk
to them right but they've somehow
managed to spend four point nine million
dollars to investigate something that is
just like you have [ __ ] up some guys
got killed some terrorists or not even
terrorists some fighters in another
country where we had our people didn't
like our people there and killed them
like that's what it comes down to now so
anyway so that kind of stuffs gonna look
there's there was a there was a fizzle
minute about it there's a three minute
trailer during the fox movie and I was
like I haven't heard of this movie but
also i'm watching something i'm like
none of this seems real and it's it's
there Batman
right it's there like Benghazi like
they're just [ __ ] batshit crazy so so
all that happens so there's 16
candidates and how they split up the
candidates is if you have like over
three percent in a poll then you can be
in the big debate and if you have less
than three percent you have to go in the
pre debate and do the two-hour
pre-debate all you have to open mic yeah
to work your way up into the you're not
even opening band you're like the band
they put on and they're like all right
you can play for free while the people
are filing in well it's like I mean I
guess it's like the reserves or the
amateurs are like the you know it's the
the Bailey it's the favor lake yeah it's
it right it is the fetal League yeah did
the fetal Republicans so the fetal guys
come out and they'd and then they try to
they try to do big crazy stuff right
because I want to get this over the game
now you know what it's like it's like a
regional wrestling Australian wrestling
so they basically you know joint you're
trying to work it out of your say and
get you character I can I think enough
the guy smashes the fluorescent light
bulb it over his head and he scratches
his face with tax it's like Benghazi all
right you're in the mind of a textbook
this is good we love it so that's all
going on explain though Trump like if it
was right if he's like because he's like
essentially playing the heel but the
popular he'll like every week like you
know he's doing that Restless nobody
goes out he's like what can I do this
week I'm gonna make fun of a [ __ ]
person yeah well Trump is the first and
that is your classic he'll behavior
totally I booing no bold I love him you
know they're like that's right i know i
don't like to handicap we love Trump for
the match against
signing contracts in the middle of the
Ring totally and then smashing the guy
in the head with a chair and the guy
dresses in Arabic building a wall in the
ring between him I do believe that he
did partake in a wrestling match in the
80s oh don't rub yeah what are the 90s
yeah we did this thing I'm grew and we
had a running joke every year we have a
like what would someone so do like it's
a kind of you know like to look at the
world's best kind of spin as a
manipulator so started with Putin
originally what would Putin do every yo
week we'd ask the question in response
to something were talking about how
Putin would solve that question then we
did like what would kim jong hoon do and
what yeah it's been various people over
the years so this year we're sitting
down you know for the start of the show
with like you know who who's the biggest
kind of spin or a manipulator in the
world what's got to be Trump right but
we're like well how are we going to do
what would trump dude we're we're not
using stuff that's in the media all the
time yeah so what we did was we went
back cuz we're sure about advertising
marketing and found all the Donald Trump
ads and stuff he's been in over the
years and so every week we would just
play some other ridiculous thing and
just got you he's running for president
did you do his game is John the game
which I own you do it was my gift at the
wrap party oh that's amazing they don't
make it anymore yeah I know it's like
monopoly he was at Donald Donald Trump
was the only guy who looked at monopoly
and went not capitalist monopoly is not
quite cover me so he yet Trump the ball
game which I have not opened at this
stage because I think if he becomes
president it might be worth something
well I ain't dad to check it down a hill
he's never gonna be President but I kept
it but at the same time people have been
saying the whole way through he's never
gonna be like I don't I'm I've not
thought I'll say the rock wasn't gonna
become the biggest factor in the world
dive but I'd never saw that i was i was
completely on the rocks and Donald Trump
is the paper stamping well here's the
interesting about Trump so our
journalists have always been able to
destroy a candidate right like
the Dean is the greatest example
halladay Howard Dean did you remember
that scream I'm gonna milk it yep no I
remember that he didn't he screamed one
thing I got taken out of content and
that's I want to he didn't even scream
oh well he went woohoo yeah and someone
took the took the audio hang on and
separated the tracks to yeah this
because of an Internet video useful no
I've seen Holly Fiorina no but I thought
I saw a news story about it later and I
was like holy [ __ ] eglin that because
they had not be true it is true they
they went someone went through and
isolated the the track and jacked it up
to make it look like he was a crazy
screaming guy when actually like one of
those goats on the internet when
actually he was the original internet
guard it was totally is totally he
actually did something like yeah and
they went all right let's hang destroyed
him he can't do that can you yeah sure
you can Tamara without a doubt and it
because because here's the thing the
media in America have always wanted to
choose the candidates and they it
there's one thing said they just go they
just attack but here's the thing they've
never had anyone like Trump or the right
we not because they whatever he says
he's like Mexicans are rapists and they
run and they type it up and I send it
out and everyone goes cool right and and
because like because we're living now in
a time when a reality star is running
for president and winning we are there
we are 20 years in to the housewives of
beverly hills oh my when Kanye I said he
was running for president at the Music
Awards I was like that is no weirder no
like I mean every most ridiculous i was
like no i don't chumps running for
pressing here Weick why wouldn't he the
biggest [ __ ] clown ever is running
for president and winning with a bunch
of people I guy who has been
ridiculously on the record being a clown
for all these years yeah has a history
of bankruptcy yeah his entire empires
built on bluster and bullying and like
you know being politically incorrect
yeah he says inappropriate things that
will get worse things any candidate has
ever said not dubbed out of his mouth no
literally the were made out of a
handicap reporter last week why not not
50 years ago or whatever like you
normally to be like oh yeah like at
University like you know you put his
dick in the mouth of a Leica whatever
and like you can't run for president
yeah you did it last week yeah it's
crazy it's completely insane like the
journals that I'll get to the point
where i'm writing this article and
donald trump is whacking his dick on my
face yeah and you [ __ ] will put him
up in the polls now it's the tip he's
hitting me with the tip ah like I've
been this I every reporter sighs in
America but sit so well but why is that
why is he this teflon person who like
what cuz always the original time we
it's all coming together it all these
things have come together one of them is
that they created this this really white
white base that could get these guys
elected and those guys have been saying
crazy [ __ ] for years in Congress but
they're just talking to each other so no
one no one really pays an attention the
press has stopped saying like the other
day uh one of the guys came out since
I'm really batshit crazy and instead of
saying instead of CNN writing a story
saying this is why he's wrong they just
said this is what he said so it's just
this is what he said it's not it's no
going through and going in this is wrong
and this is wrong in this wrong so
they've been doing that for a long time
and now that's catching up on them
because now they have this guy who's
just saying [ __ ] but also people are so
[ __ ] our government is so [ __ ] up
and people are so [ __ ] tired of it
and Trump is a guy who's just sticking
his finger up and going [ __ ] you
government and everyone's like yes so
there is totally that part of it like
there are just people who want a guy to
go in there and say go [ __ ] yourselves
and I totally get that one hundred
percent our government is [ __ ] up and
corrupt and needs to be torn down right
but night but the wrong guy yes right
that's like you hearing your pilot matta
as he gets on the like white plains of
[ __ ]
I'm not you know what list it lets you
gonna have that opinion but he's what I
was I let someone else flaw Italy but is
there but there isn't another candidate
with in all those candidates who is like
a legitimate crazy outside or populist
guy who will say what the people want to
hear which he is doing let's face it
what we're learning is that those people
I'm not saying all Republicans because I
know a lot of Republicans who don't know
what's happening right now but there are
plenty of Republicans or just [ __ ]
dicks and just hate everything and they
hate the Mexicans and they hate the
transgendered and they hate all the [ __ ]
that he's talking about and so they're
like yeah just ate it's very it's very
reality show it's very I love to see
this guy tell people their [ __ ] heads
and then fire them it's what it is it's
what they want from him he's doing it he
it this is running man right I mean it
just sometimes you do look around and go
if I was watching a movie like you know
say the purge for example yeah I so the
purge it's our the bird that's I always
write that about him on Twitter it's
like we're like two days away from him
saying all right get shotguns it's five
o'clock right yeah it's like those purge
movies are gonna date so badly I can a
fake this purchase so there may guys in
trucks like them come perch I know is
just people would just go down the
street and murder everything that moved
giant packs that's the purge I'm chef I
mean it's crazy okay so so all that's
happening and so now the press has no
ability to destroy anyone the parties
don't have any ability to pull anybody
back it's totally out of control it's
just it's like a system that's out of
control people want to destroy the
system the system has been telling
basically the American the American
government has been telling the people
to go [ __ ] themselves for so long now
that this is inevitable now on the other
side you have Bernie Sanders who is
exactly what you want he is reasonable
he's the most liked person in Congress
he is very smart he's very very populist
and he's perfectly
reasonable man which is funny because
the Democrats would not that guy could I
think that guy he was if he was made the
candidate he would annihilate Trump and
everybody else but the Democrats are
gonna picked Hillary who is who is who
represents everything that we're tired
of so good luck I don't know what's
gonna happen there right but Hillary's
John saner and Bernie Sanders is Sam
punk yeah i mean that's exactly that it
was like we actually want Punk but he's
frustrated with the system you know I
understand all right yeah yeah so all
that shit's coming together and then in
the middle of that you have Isis right
which is created by them created by the
Republicans so I did a whole dollop
about it it's it breaks down how they
[ __ ] created these [ __ ] and then
they shoot up Paris so it's a [ __ ] you
know which is which is the you can't
even get it how complicated the French
the French situation is with years of
keeping them letting the live in the
country not be citizens just on that on
the edge of like of the society growing
more and more like it's so [ __ ]
complicated that you can't look at that
go [ __ ] Muslim it's just so deeply
rooted and [ __ ] up like I mean well of
course so all these that I mean
absolutely like radicalize people being
disenfranchised it's it's it's a
breeding ground yeah regardless of the
you know the endless debate you could
have on the a variety of issues around
this topic the one thing that you can't
it's like it's perfect conditions yeah
you get a you but your bomber country
for 14 years you killed civilians in
that country that country doesn't have
access to outside news feeds or media to
get any perspective on why you're doing
it what they see is people who were
innocent for civilians being killed by
people in the name of something going to
find weapons that weren't there that
they made up in the first place to fix a
rock and now they're fixing here with
bombs or whatever and again this is not
me saying in it in any way defending
[ __ ] Isis because the whole point is
like you lose any credibility and
argument when you kill civilians
both the whole point of the other thing
is America Australia the Coalition of
the Willing have all been killing
civilians in the name of war as well but
forever and if you're in a place where
you're seeing civilians be killed and
you are a disenfranchised person and
then you move to somewhere that is also
where your disenfranchised then you're
consoling your own groups and you treat
is a second class citizen it doesn't
doesn't give permission for people to go
there but you want to make a terrorist
that's how you do it that's how you know
that's exactly I do if you wanted you
someone's hand really need to make some
terrorists how can I do that oh I got I
got a boo-boo want this either yeah I
got it right here Michael by Matt a
movie about it instant terrace that's
yet so I've been watching all this
second bill maher and all these stupid
[ __ ] say Muslims are all they're all
trying to kill us and you're just like I
mean I know some they don't I know they
don't want to kill me just for my own
personal experience I've met a few
perfectly reasonable and heaps of people
want to kill you it tons of like you're
unlikely a theist one right on me no
absolutely and like I mean this is a
topic that's come up of course it is in
Australia it's the same thing right
absolutely and and we're getting the
same you know stupid messages about like
you know we have the same right-wing
commentators and whatever coming out and
calling on you know all Muslims to speak
out against you know ba ba ba and all
this sort of stuff so I mean right don't
get me wrong like I think that religion
gives extremist and religion across the
board also home I mean if you give
people a reason to think hey my life is
shitty here but if I do this thing I go
to some sort of paradise yeah you like I
mean it gives them of course like I mean
they say you know if you set up a
[ __ ] if you set up a door for after
you're dead where there's great things
happening what do you [ __ ] thinks
gonna happen right it doesn't mean that
everybody's but it can be used in that
way and they saved a lot of Isis people
this is one of the more interesting
things because again with all these
things mostly they're disenfranchised
young young men that's basically what it
is everywhere everywhere surprised and
angry women yeah and so you get these
young men a lot of the Murex gang
members yes and so what you do is they
recruit these people who already violent
who are already looking for a community
away from the mainstream yeah and they
offer them an opportunity to have a
[ __ ] you know it just gets wiped your
[ __ ] slate clean and go to this place
where you know you can be a murder I
mean that's again they also pay them
they give them jobs which they can't get
in a place with their second class
citizens right I mean some of our just
taking it as a [ __ ] like a paper
route it's a job you're giving someone
an opportunity and a reason and religion
also gives it that extra factor then you
can believe in this thing and religions
of all kinds over these have been used
to justify that sort of [ __ ] so because
I my things always like again I just
draw your line at what you believe when
you hurt someone else so you heard it an
innocent person you can believe whatever
you [ __ ] want about your religion but
you can't hurt somebody oh you don't get
to hurt me like you don't get to put
your [ __ ] [ __ ] rules on me
because I'm not part of your [ __ ]
religion but you can have your aren't
you can leave your own why use I was a
knock yourself out have a good time over
there that's great regardless overly now
you've you've I've heard you talk about
religion in your act I've never I've
never you won't go find me tell you
about religion anywhere I've just
straight I've just completely stayed
away from so but watching all of these
[ __ ] idiots say Muslim Muslims
control your other Muslims and just it's
just been building and building building
and watching bill maher is the biggest
[ __ ] clueless [ __ ] in America
about it as far as I'm concerned because
he did so much damage because he's
supposed to be a liberal which he's not
but he just keeps saying and bringing on
people to explain to us why they're a
murderous religion and I look at all
religions have been used to murder that
includes Buddhist and Hindu they all
have [ __ ] gotten on on their horses
and gone and slaughtered people oj
Howard it's good to finally hear a
moderate comedian speak out against
extremism and damaging messages of Bill
Maher on behalf of comedian so that is
very positive the Muslims could take a
lead from you Dave Anthony so I watched
this and I was like Jesus Christ telling
do we have to put up with his [ __ ] it's
building in its building and so then
then then
and I'm I am like the Christians have
killed so many [ __ ] people since the
beginning of Christianity that it's
insane I mean the Crusades the like they
all they just have that's just what they
do they kiss off and there and I know
plenty of great Christians I'm not I'm
not condemning all Christianity I know
some that lived their lives and they and
they're very good people and they use it
for the right things but unfortunately
when you create something like that you
also invited monsters that how it works
yep so I made that tweet and I went to
10,000 and for the day after it was
[ __ ] insane just barrage after broch
and then I and then I started and I was
just getting likes people how do you
know he was a Christian and I was just
like oh he's raised Baptist he has a
cross on the front of his house and he
shot the Planned Parenthood and he
yelled no more baby parts which is their
chant yep their current chant and then I
started to notice something really weird
I started to notice people call him
female so people responding on Twitter
started saying he's a female okay now
I'm really this is I mean this is Tyga
de crying guy in mask twisted I was not
expecting and I've also I've also talked
about this but my next one man show
which I do next not this year next year
it's gonna be about guns and my personal
relationship with guns yeah how I view
it in Australia the cold guns I've got
some issues in America will be called
why guns are great we all agree that's
right ya go everything's good let's get
me calle guns yeah Young and Dan are
strange many call yay guns and now you
guys that's the Australian version no
guns so um so I'm so i'm i am on one
hand watching these idiots and shutting
them down but other ones i want to talk
to like other ones i am cool I'm
purposefully zero-sum I'm looking for
material some I'm purposely badgering
because I'd see they're crazy and so I'm
just I'm just kind of dialoguing with
all these different people and then it
goes from him being female to him being
transgender so now they're telling me
there we go
loss sir now they're telling me and have
you seen a picture of the shooter not a
gray-haired guy uh-huh with a big crazy
beard and giant crazy hair that sticks
up I am hey what oh yeah that's I said
Liam Liam like that we call that little
later in Australia you know hey you guys
had the Rachel friends that was got the
Rachel we had to Liam I was I was named
after a Liam Neeson movie that he did in
Australia tracking down an angry he
tried to track down the dingo oh ok so
he just looks like if Santa went out
with Nick Nolte for a night yeah totally
that would be the mug shot if they found
a guy who played Santa and Nick Nolte in
a car together and they had their mug
shots side by side that's what it would
look like ok is exactly what it was like
so hang on why is this guy transgender
well that's obviously obviously what I'm
getting what I'm from I make that tweet
and then I'm getting responses how do
you know he's Christian and then I say
well he has a cross on his house he was
raised Baptist he shadow play a parent
hood and he's saying this phrase right
and then I get bad enough of this
[ __ ] ok [ __ ] he's a
transgendered female ok so it's a female
dressed as a min it's a female just as a
man and the like dressed as a man
transgender is trans transitioned into a
man right ok and I'm like so what in the
[ __ ] is happening and then they're
saying here and now this is probably a
bad dice joy but I can't go past it
Santa's lossy sec I'm a no offense I
just feel like that's a good joke so so
now I'm at the point where I'm just
bewildered like I have no idea what's
happening so I start trying to research
it and find it and it then someone sends
me up a screen capture and it's above
voter registration form now if you
anything about America you know that
people who isolate and and live in rural
places have started to really hate the
government to the point that they're
killing cops and killing census census
takers they've killed census takers
because a man comes and knocks on your
door
says hey we won't know how many people
live here will you [ __ ] kill him
right well the the guy running for
president Heights government yes I why
wouldn't that ordinary people hate
government that is correct if you're
going your elected officials are telling
you that those people are bad and they
come to your door then they're bad right
right so this guy wrote on his voter
registration that he's female probably
because and I'm just hazarding a guess
he's [ __ ] nuts right and he's
probably anti-government across the
board and he doesn't want to know who he
is or what he's doing so they took that
registration farm and they've and they
wait this is how it happens with a lot
of transgender people it starts with the
voting for I mean that's I guess that's
when you think about it i'm polling yet
you know hold on now i just i don't know
i mean no one's really asked me what sex
I was until I filled in this fall it's
been a pretty long it's been a while
it's been a long time what it doesn't
come up day to day it doesn't nobody
says male or female and now now that is
this form with m / f and this is an
official government fine so do I want to
go into a voting booth to people
thinking that I have a man when I feel
like a woman I guess that's I mean you
know that could be the start of the
journey okay he's he's a question I have
that is even not about this but it is a
kind of about this who when someone
shoots up a planned parenthood is
suddenly googling their voter
registration forms jamaica land where is
that now has that even been introduced
into this debate so quickly well it's
the first thing we do huh well i can
tell you they i can tell you exactly how
happened they they check to see if he
was a Democrat a Republican I don't want
to tell you that blind when I believe it
I believe it did say Democrat on there
like he just went the opposite of who he
was what seibel who do who are against
the government so he said he was a
female Democrat yeah so they were like
ah ah right we've got it and
transgendered I'm a nice thing right now
because because some places want to want
to allow transgender people who use the
you know the bathroom of their choice
and the right wing
just can't believe what's happening I
guess he got it the right way Oh though
because I mean I guess if you're a
female you'd probably want to be a
Democrat they probably look out for the
little bit more but once you transition
to being a man you wanna be one of
Puppets they look after the guys I mean
story checks out so far I guess sorry
totally jegs out yeah no I agree and
like transgender even else having this
conversation and trying to laugh about
this thing you you feel like it's one of
those things where like these days
because of weather debates out and
whatever you don't want to like say
something unintentionally disrespectful
lifeand but what's happening it has
become a cause for a certain side of yes
politics and is now it's a big thing
right now and coincidentally and you're
not going to believe this but more
transgendered people have been killed
this year than any other year in the
history united states of america is that
right isn't that strange that happens
when our politicians are talking about
how bad they are and then they should
stay in their place that they suddenly
start getting killed it look weird the
thing that came off the off to Paris
because it happened in Australia a bit
with some people who weren't a lot of
Muslim women are being yelled at yes
street what's happening here and yeah
but they think that thing again I'm this
is not you have to look up whatever the
[ __ ] fact of this is but in America
after nine eleven did you know that they
killed like of 66 like anybody with
anybody brown with a beard right the
fact that they were selling cakes can I
see the [ __ ] turban on their head or
whatever I don't know what it's called
but but it looks to them like a turban
rightly it looks like an Arab turban to
them because they live in cartoon 1940s
right and they start shooting guys who
are seeks I mean it's yeah I mean we are
we are a nation of [ __ ] idiots I mean
that's crazy yeah but we are that that's
one thing you learn when you do this and
you have a tweet that gets ten thousand
retweets you you really get confronted
with how [ __ ] stupid we are and not
stupid because we didn't get taught in
school willfully stupid right we're
choosing to be ignorant because I had
people because i would get good tato I
was the first American special day
willfully stupid I I would get very nice
Christians who I would talk to there's a
pastor in Pennsylvania there's a woman
from here and there and I would discuss
with them and i would i would have
interesting conversations in which they
would say well he's not a christian and
i would say why and they would say
because Christians don't do that and i
would say what christian do do this and
here's the historical documents to prove
it and then they would say well that's
not my addition if inition of a
christian i don't believe he's a
Christian I go that doesn't mean he's
not a Christian right you get into that
kind of circular [ __ ] which is
totally fine like I respect that your
opinion you can actually say he's not a
Christian but he's a Christian because
he calls himself a Christian right I but
at the same way is like one of the I was
gonna say audience one of the supporters
of my football club last year racially
vilified a player from another club that
guy back from my club you know like he
was one of our fans yeah now I don't
think he represents in the club you know
straight away were like you know this
person doesn't represent us here's what
we're doing to address that blah blah
blah and I'm glad that I support a club
that did that yeah but at the same time
you like but he was still I can't say
that he wasn't one of our supporters he
was married our jumper he like bear
outside and he was racist to a player on
the field people [ __ ] jump into your
group that's just part of the thing you
have to deal with look we had a comedian
Vince champ who was going around raping
people for years he would go to schools
and rape rape girls in colleges he was a
comedian he was one of her [ __ ] tribe
and and comedians are a weird group ago
around the country doing [ __ ] like that
is an open invitation for a guy who's
got bad intentions to jump into that
grub I mean he's did like I it was a
terrible terrible thing that he did and
by ripping off Cosby's material like at
all those venues again again that's a
terrace I'm so sorry I'm sorry horrible
joke so so it it just I've never because
I've never gone into the religion thing
because I just I just think like yeah
yeah I get it it's the magical man in
the sky go live your [ __ ] life but
but now we're getting to a point where
there are so many shootings that are
being justified because
people apparently think Jesus would have
been packing right there's so many
Americans who are hardcore christians
who are walking around with ak-47s on
their back that it's but now like a now
is the time you can't just say anti-gun
it's all wrapped up in one [ __ ] and you
can't just separate it it's you are a
crazy you are exactly what they are if
there were no laws in America if it was
like Syria they would be killing us yeah
but that's that's because dive and this
is the problem you haven't read the
whole Bible you you've just read the the
old part the Old Testament in the New
Testament but why you haven't read is
the chapter 3 yeah Michael Bay the Bible
was called the Bible and Jesus did hates
more shooting one of their robots yeah
jesus was back and this time it was
personal that was Jesus and then he came
out of the cave with a bunch of Uzis and
she got [ __ ] up Jesus is back and he's
tired of socialism uh yeah what do you
say hey chicas you Jesus what happened
you can have my gun when you get it out
of my cold dead recently owned undead
hence my second time around dead hands
second to hear back from the dead hands
you can have my gun when you get it on
my back to Britain from the dead hands
now you have been outspoken about
religion do you think you have I want to
ask you for a while I don't know if I
wrap do you think you have a lot of
Christian fans you just ignore that part
of what you say well the outside a
couple of things about that I think that
my general philosophy about talking
about religion and generally is the way
that I do talk about it is within the
context of what the [ __ ] would right now
yeah like I literally don't know I
always talk about what I believe in and
then I talked about like problems you
know essentially like you know my rule
has always been very simply right to
swing your fear stops another person's
face believe whatever [ __ ] yeah
ridiculous thing you want to believe and
who am I to you know tell you you're
ridiculous thing that you believe is any
diff
to my ridiculous thing that I believe we
all as human beings there is no we don't
know what the purpose of this earth or
will I for anything is yeah everything
that we do every day is guesswork like
how we're meant to be filling our lives
what the purpose of those lives are I
personally you know don't think that our
brains are big enough to comprehend if
there is some sort of explanation for
that or if we are just randomly what
happened in the corner of the universe
that blows my mind even more like I mean
the idea and maybe this is something I
was I was thinking maybe there's
something I might even try to explore in
the new show is the fact that you know
every year I go to that on my birthday
if I'm here in LA I go to the
observatory and i watch that history of
the universe show that and I [ __ ]
love it but there's this moment in it
where they show where we are you know
they project on the roof you know where
we are in the universe and they show how
little we are and that we're not the
center of it in any way we are a tiny
pocket in this tiny [ __ ] corner of
the universe and I explain the nature of
life and all these sort of things and
there's only two conclusions I think you
could ever walk away from that knowledge
which is like one of them is well if
this is what we are then there must be
something more to it because why would
it be this or to me which is what I
probably believe is that like you know
that there is that we are just an
accident in the corner of the universe
and for whatever reason it is it's this
but or that our brains at least aren't
at the evolved we're not at the point in
our evolution as a species okay we can
walk and talk and we can do this sort of
stuff but there's a point well beyond
where we are right now that we may
finally comprehend if there is some sort
of nature or reason or whatever it was
or pattern or need for us to be right
yeah but I don't think we will ever know
that in our lives no but if that is true
like if I honestly believe that to be
true and I do I think honestly believe
that to be true then why the [ __ ] is at
this like what is this like what is the
purpose you know just a purely
accidental the evolutionary sense of you
and I city in this [ __ ] table with
those microphones making this or me
drinking this on me like what the hey
why would this be necessary to anything
I think there's no difference between us
and a guy with six fingers
one time a day a long long time ago
something was born and it was smarter
than the other things and there was a
little family of them and they went and
started doing things and they could
capitalize and they could take advantage
because they were smarter and from that
it became what we are it's just a
mistake it's just a natural mutation and
it happened to be that we are smart it
could have it could have very well been
that a giant idiot killed the smart ones
and that was the end of it yeah and then
we're still monkeys running around we
just got lucky so I think we're just so
you think that this is old purely
evolutionary like you know the fact it
like new yeah so and that society is set
up you know in much in the way that like
you know there are people who are
necessary to be workers there are people
who are necessary to be leaders there
are people in for a society to keep
going right yeah I mean that may be true
but in that you know like they say then
in the timeline were a blip and I think
we will be a blip I think we will I
think that we will end ourselves oh yeah
well it's that famous Colin thing you
know the planet is the planets the
planets fine that was it that he's being
right I remember when I first saw him do
that bit about the planets fine we're
fine yeah you know like the planet the
planets known it'll still be well as a
matter of fact the planet had something
on it right now it needs it needs to get
rid of yeah we're a parasite they
totally destroying the flabby are
completely and you know what the
definition of a parent's a play have you
seen Jurassic Park the planet is shaken
off [ __ ] havin us who's bigger and
scarier and more impressive in the
planet just yet we're whatever yeah so I
don't I don't I mean I don't get into
the outside this one's gotta say to
answer that really quickly is so i think
that like when i do do my religious
stuff then people i think generally like
and I've had Christian you know feedback
from Christians and stuff saying that
they find my perspective in the show not
offensive and yeah you know if I you
know and I would say that most of people
come to my show of people who already
believe in the same way as those people
you talk to or like well they're not
real Christians I bet that these people
who come and see my my shows would think
yeah yeah the people we're talking about
are not real Christians you know the
things that I'm talking about
them a bit if you were a real Christian
if you really believed in Christianity
and you saw your show you would go let's
see that he doesn't get it right that
would be your that would be your that
would be if you were a real and really
deeply data Christian and believed it
that would be your response let's see
bad because it's the ones who get
offended and want to kill you well
they're having doubts right and they
want to kill you that you want to kill
you because you're if you're the voice
if you're strong enough in your own
belief why would it matter what it
shouldn't matter at all so yeah that
should not be able to hurt you if you
believe what you believe I just did a
podcast recently mobile losophy one with
the guy called Aaron Burkina who's a
chaplain and you know a lover of Jesus
and we spoke for two hours and it was
brilliant and yeah you know to talk to
him and I respect these perspective on
religion and the role that you know
because he follows Jesus like that's his
big thing right he'd be as critical of
this yeah of course you how could you
not be if he truly followed the word of
Jesus and why Jesus lived his life how
can you not look at what's happening
right now go this is [ __ ] crazy I
mean in Australia Tony Abbott literally
said jesus knew there was a place for
everybody and not everybody's place was
in Australia like well no no that's
actually now he was a refugee remember
turma that bit of the Bible about them
are you been reading the Bible great guy
i want i want i wish i could i wish i
had the money to do a short film and and
I could get Ted Nugent because I want I
want to do a film of Jesus coming back
and the first thing he does is take a
helicopter ride with Ted Nugent and
watch him shoot pigs out of his
helicopter right just to watch his face
just just on the face of Jesus not just
a little watching a guy punches like
we'll get one camera locked on Jesus's
face just his face as he was like how
[ __ ] this went so wrong oh you know what
you need to do this would be great it
geez if Jesus does come back it's just a
series of those internet reaction videos
well so you get Jesus first look at eye
doctor
show him a series of things that have
been done in his name and you just say
he's reacting one Jesus two cubs cuz the
mannish it has been done in his name
just just in America alone is
mind-boggling and when you get when you
make a tweet like I did you get so
confronted with those people okay who
are [ __ ] terrifying whoo-hoo just say
you should [ __ ] die you liberal bit
just just the craziest and all I would
write back is just very Christian of you
and then they would just [ __ ] lose
their [ __ ] even more but it's true
you're nothing like I'm more like Jesus
and you are firstly I've just started
doing something no I think you I'm more
like Jesus than you okay so I've just
started doing this thing and I II don't
I I think I'm gonna keep doing it
because I'm quite enjoying it which is
when somebody who is it only an egg
profile on Twitter you know who've still
got the tag those are dangerous i send
me you know nasty and I say yeah some
nasty ones and like video unions yeah
and if you have opinions that's when you
get attacked and I have opinion so I got
attacked all the time and you know end
is a certain i mean there's a stray lien
general school Clementine fault is a
feminist ride and provocative or
provocative but I think of a person
needed in this time who's intentionally
provocative to make you a lot of points
right and she wrote something the other
day and like she then just published all
the like just as it justice so what
people said back to it was head back to
her and it was some of the most horrible
things I've ever seen in my life so I
never get rape threats or death threats
right away that like women get on the
internet I was like that I will say this
the worst people who responded to me by
far not even not even comparable
Christian gamers are you someone who had
Christian and gamer in their bio were
[ __ ] monsters well because that's you
know what the shooting at the Planned
Parenthood was all about it takes in
games journalists
what if Jesus came back and he was like
look all this was about where i was
going on time was ethics they stumbled
upon it but and people would say and
I've tweeted time about that and some
and people like you know what gamers
aren't that bad I'm like I'm sorry
you're acting like I'm not a gamer like
I haven't put on headphones and play
video games I have never heard more vile
heinous things said that in a [ __ ]
video game lobby it's crazy they are
monsters I mean finally a moderate gyma
space tight now Muslims so eggs yeah so
when you get the egg responding in the
old days I used to you know just I would
just lay right back whatever horrible
thing they'd written to me I just like
um you know you can change that profile
picture from an egg and like I would
show yer yeah I would just like I know
we'd like right so he asked by Kevin no
but seriously like if you want me to run
you through it yeah but that they didn't
say no really but so now just I did this
first time the other day but I've done
it twice since and I feel like it's
gonna keep going is now I tweet them
back in an egg recipe yeah like no
explanation no no that's my favorite
thing about it is like when anyone who's
an egg just but I just tweet back an egg
recipe and then that's it then i put
them on mute so i don't even say what
happens after that that's great because
it's so nonsensical the thing I've been
doing is everyone's well just send
backup just out of nowhere someone some
of you mean tweet not just rub somebody
tweeted says hey have you ever taken off
your shirts and rub bellies with another
guy and then they just explode and it
like okay it's all good I want to find
out more about this but I need to go to
bathroom song and a pause so what else
did you learn from these people who
responded to you i mean the the
you know I guess because I stay out of
the religion arguments I just completely
sort of avoid it because I when I was
starting out in comedy there are a lot
of people doing that kind of stuff but
we were also friends with a christian
comedian who was really [ __ ] funny
like he did really great jokes and I
talked to him about it once it was very
sort of unassuming and very nice guy he
just kind of kept himself and and I was
just like I just don't want to piss
people off like that because because in
while there are [ __ ] there are just
a lot of really nice people that are
Christians right and so I was like I
it's so easy for a lot of comedians
really [ __ ] easy well I made it it's
and don't get me wrong I'm sure like I i
I'm sure and when I say I'm sure I'm
positive because you know I know that
this is the case where there was
certainly an element of me you know when
I say 25 or whatever there was very much
of that like you know if you believe in
religion than you're a [ __ ] idiot
yeah a lot of that but hopefully you
grow out of that like an you have a more
nuanced perspective and sometimes when I
see people these days do a bit of like
you know going hey God isn't real you're
like a year no I got that when I was 12
like and I got a bit angry about mo
early Chinese but it were being I'm
agnostic like I God could be real I
don't [ __ ] know [ __ ] at the end of
the day I mean that's not what I believe
right well know what I think he's a god
could choke when I get back ah [ __ ] i
blew that up well I just have that bit
in my act where I would literally have
that joke of like you know I don't know
how the [ __ ] would I know I'd like I you
save a joke it was like you know I
didn't understand the end of donnie
darko how am I meant to know whether
there's a [ __ ] god or not you know
many of God walks up one day and he's
like hi I'm god I'll be like okay my bad
high five hey what are the rules hey I
was all about ethics and games
journalist oh my god what seriously uh
yeah I mean absolutely like the
possibility there is some sort of God or
some sort of like [ __ ] matrix or some
sort of whatever like you know i watch
the matrix the other night and yes I was
stoned but I was watching the matrix
come yeah this makes about as much sense
as any other [ __ ] theory you know like
then you know but we don't know that and
here's what I do know that there's a
bunch of people in this world who all
essentially are looking
for some sort of explanation or purpose
too you know yeah the world and how it
works you know and a lot of them believe
in in some sort of creator or God and
many of the stories have similar sort of
like medicine you know whatever
crossover in the middle of them there's
a need in human beings at this point in
our evolution for people still believe
in God's you know yes part of our world
I have no problem with that is it it's
Toria we love stories but a story but
it's this idea that rather than looking
for like a higher purpose or an
explanation of life so that we can get
together that there's a set of rules
that were laid down it's like the
Constitution like you know the idea that
like something that people came up with
you know 250 years ago is still a
relevant document to what happens today
they update the [ __ ] itunes agreement
yeah every six [ __ ] money italy but
not that one no no can't [ __ ] with that
one because some people who [ __ ] in the
streets I mean they go why did people
get so they were got mad it back to the
future for not getting everything about
the future right do you say I'm mad
people were about that it's a [ __ ]
movie it's a comedy movie people were so
angry that I didn't know everything
about the future you were expecting that
[ __ ] you know some [ __ ] 2000
years ago who wrote down some stories
right who are like man we got to give
this thing together fast because that
right there's some [ __ ] coming down the
pike but also the Bible's like one of
those oral histories they do of like
Saturday Night Live if you know where
it's not it's not a documentary they
will like this is people's recollections
right happen way [ __ ] later right way
later white letter a hundred years yeah
when it started getting written down so
yeah eh it's essentially like they got
the kids of people who were in saturday
night live at to do an oral history of
Saturday Night Live stories they just
heard from their parents and [ __ ]
Belushi's grandson and they didn't get
why they couldn't even get like they got
a Jim Belushi's crater
Jim Belushi years right but that's the
thing you don't get although no one
remembers at the same everyone remembers
things differently or whatever and then
too and that's that's fine if we go well
this is a gist of it this is what people
thought at the time or their
interpretation of what went on at the
time but it's a living document that we
probably interpret differently at this
time is like you know maybe the burning
bush wasn't talked to him maybe he was
having some sort of psychotic you might
have been having a mental breakdown
right point still might I mean if we saw
a guy talking to a burning bush now we'd
be like we should call the place I'm
aiming a loaded situation like if a guy
in the street if you're walking down
Sunset Boulevard and there was a guy
talking to abortion that you turned
around and said this is how you should
live your life the bush told me yeah you
probably like um we're just going to eat
at the hamlet right I mean technically
as a country you twice said no we want
to listen to a bush so not three times
they were like ah night Rita oh you know
what you can get us twice only twice no
not this time but there's something
worse we can pick [ __ ] that's got to be
also by the way Gerald the whole time
like when your dad and your brother have
been president of right and you've
always been kind of late seen almost
seemed like you had a bit of a creative
like now he's the reason actual this
nice that they were said yeah he said he
was the smart one he's the one he's the
one with me any apparently in the family
always felt like George jumped in front
of min line right president like they
were both gonna be President but his
brother jumped the line is what he has
always felt we didn't know that actually
there it was possible that there could
be someone dumber than George Bush right
and uh just just how did you look at
these guys like how did you ever get
elected governor you're a [ __ ] idiot
right you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] but he is
he somehow worst as well but he was
never gonna get elected because the
collective damage even the Republicans
of turning is George Bush they're like
now you don't it's no you don't get to
talk about anything that's it Cheney
that's it weird good with you zip it so
here's what I would say
I noticed how I so I have this I have
this image in my head that most
Christians are nice people yes and then
there's a few that are [ __ ] [ __ ]
yes which I still believe right but
there are also a few people who are
pushing guns in our country it's not a
large amount of people it's a very small
small small minority of people pushing
that and they're the same [ __ ] people
and I and I I can't sit on the sidelines
anymore as someone who does what I do
does that make sense my comedy is very
personal I can't do that anymore I have
to I'm smart and I have a lot of [ __ ]
ideas of what things are and what
they're not and i can put [ __ ] together
that a lot of people can't and i have to
start putting it together are you about
to announce that you're running for
president i'm running for the president
ice age of America Anthony the West
that'll be a great election Kanye of
against Dave who I mean I got to be
honest with you I I'd like to say that
i'd like to see Anthony of a kanye in
the presidential election it would be
such good election 1 20 20 20 20 20 20
hey V Kanye but I just had to start
[ __ ] putting my [ __ ] i have a [ __ ]
podcast that people listen to and i can
i can put things together and give
people knowledge and my stand-up I can't
I just can't sit there and talking about
personal stuff anymore i have to blow
open it up and do this kind of stuff
looked at it's interesting to me because
it's too important for people not to
what do you think the important bit is
like what I mean because I wrestled with
this all the time and I think about this
all the time I'm about to write a new
show and it's always liable what is it
that I want to say or what is it that I
need to say I just did this show about
Australian politics in Australia and
like weirdly enough Amy who does not
like politics not like news and politics
and so I was almost going to say to her
don't come to the show because she
doesn't even read the newspaper yeah
like she says to me all the time and I
think it's such a brilliant thing she
goes I said but you know what if this
like something big that happens in the
world she goes well something big
happens in the world you
hear about it haha and she was like I
was like but what if it was something
medium-sized that would be important to
you but wouldn't necessarily be
something that everybody knew about and
she goes well you'd tell me and I was
like oh sure and that is that is a good
point so oh my god there's a lot of
people who live their life like that
okay but she came into my political show
and she said to me afterwards and I'm
gonna do some more of it next year based
on this yeah in fact I ran my manager
who had wanted me to do more of this
political show but I was putting it away
because I had my new show to write um
but my manager and my producer most
loved the show as well but I I was done
with it I was like okay well I'm done
now I've done the show that's that's it
and then Amy came and saw him and it was
the day of the parachuting so we that
morning had sat I two shows to do that
day it was the last day of the tour and
it's a show that is like a lot of it is
about you know these very asylum seekers
and terrorism and you know all these
sort of things and so we'd SAT there
that morning for three hours and watched
you know we got up that morning and we'd
had a personal connection not that I
want to in any way make this about me
because it's not about me but I just
explaining what we had that so amy is
friends with the band The Eagles of
Death Watch Jesus really like friendly
like you know and to the point where
she's still like one of the guys in the
band you know her in her correspond
quite a lot mo she's hung out with them
before you know secondly again not to
make it about us in any way but just to
put in perspective where we were that
day we love Paris we one of our best
holidays we ever had was embarrassed we
had a great time there and we love that
band and in some ways even more than 911
for us like we both things that we saw
from a distance and that you still are
affected by we were like if we were in
Paris we would have been at that showed
that not generate as in like because
that's like the semi thing we was only
card i mighta gone to that mean Amy
knows the band we would have been you
guys definitely I mean yeah the
Australian girl who was shot who
survived but who was shot again it seems
we do even talk about in your own
personal history but is what I'm trying
to say I they the first thing they like
when the Australian give a shot of
course let you know what the media do
these days in Australia is they go to
their Facebook I know
in America they go firstly to their
voter registration forms what's the
gender yeah it turns out she was a man
she was an ID year old man but now she
was a 19 year old girl but the header
photo on her Facebook page I was a photo
of me and Sam Simmons together in bed
from like a thing that we did and like
so she's obviously I guess like a fan of
Samson fine as well oh that I saw you
yeah I swear yeah yeah so that was the
girl who got the Australian girl got
shot and so suddenly you just have this
kind of thing of going yeah right this
is like it just feels at least in your
world and yeah both Amy and I just SAT
there for three hours watching the news
unfold that morning because it was like
in Australia on a Saturday morning so
basically when we got up it was still in
process and write those next few hours
you know who I went on for a long time
right so we watch that all pretty much
live and then I was I've got to do a
shot I've got to do two shows today I
don't know how I'm going to do that so
we went out the house so we walked the
dogs and went for lunch and just tried
to shake it off a bit but you couldn't
take it off on that day because
everywhere you win I didn't even know if
people who come to the show like I was
like I can imagine like I didn't
necessarily even want to do the show
that day like I was like you know I
don't know I'm not sure how I like even
this show at least in this show I feel
like I'm doing something talking about
something important but i don't think
i'm talking about anything important
enough right like in the way that i
should be talking about on a day like
this so anyway they came she came to the
show and she loved it which was amazing
today but she was said to me she said it
was a favorite show that she'd seen a
mine which you know that I respect her
opinion on that and it so I'm going to
do it again but it also made me think a
lot about like longer i've got this new
show too right maybe i should be writing
something you know that is a bit more in
that area not about Australia but about
the work you know yeah like you said
like I mean you have a an audience and
you have a so but what is it that you
think that you want to say because this
is this is where it becomes problematic
for me is I get to this point where I'm
like yes it's it's important than I you
know that I use this opportunity that I
have to say something important but then
the bit that I the stumbling block is
going well what the [ __ ] do I know like
what the [ __ ] can I say or what the [ __ ]
can I say that is valuable too
to bite or this conversation well I I
haven't seen anybody talk about it from
a personal experience a comedian okay so
I had that experience I talked about
this i'm walking the room i might have
talked about on here when i was in
Seattle with my with my wife and kid and
we were in a restaurant a fairly nice
restaurant and a guy came in who looked
a little off and he had his hand in his
pocket and everyone thought he had a gun
and it went on for quite some time to me
everyone's talking about guns from this
big broad thing but it needs to be
humanized right and the fact that I can
go out to dinner and be scared is wrong
because we've made a choice right that I
should be scared we've collectively made
a choice that I should be terrified I
mean it's our decision it's one of those
things and again like I find it very
hard as an outsider when you come to
America because I'm very conscious of
the fact that this is not my country
though it is a country that I am
choosing to spend part of my life in and
hope that you know I can be part of like
I would like to see I jumped on America
like you know to mean like right we got
a bad time like you I mean you at least
were [ __ ] born here you had no choice
I had no choice but words I've like you
know oh my oh no this is still good this
looks like a good place to go right now
like yeah I mean I like I wasn't even a
guy who bought it at the top of the
market going to be good forever right we
already knew that things were gone wrong
when I jumped on board you know sure but
that idea of even like a no and I did
think about it as I saw that shooting
I'm like what if I had a family like you
know and I think about this all the time
it's like I just wouldn't raise my
children here I just couldn't as a
parent like I mean I'm not saying that
you I'm not but you mean like well as
someone who has a choice between the two
countries there I just could not in my
mind think that I would raise kids in
America when I could raise them in
Australia right so no one's talking
about what happens BAM was talking about
you know guns and okay Kate let's take
this example so a couple months ago I
have very we have a very good friend and
my son Finn has become very good friends
with their daughter and they they love
each other and the hang out all the time
Roman
ceramic it could be something do you
think it is like a hello t5 he takes
he's six okay she's six and six is it
because I remember when I was six there
was definitely like a girl that was more
my friend of course she was my friend
but at the same time everyone kind of
kind of tay's that she was my girlfriend
cuz we hung out a little yeah we don't
do hit it's kind of like maybe there's
times where I'm like man I'm their 16
and they're gonna do something totally a
thing I don't know what's gonna but it's
dead they have a connection a huge
connection yeah quite so that girl goes
to a different school than Finn she's a
lil bit of a richer community and shed
it but she hasn't [ __ ] to good friends
at her school yep and one of those was a
boy and one night his father came home
and shot his mom and then drove to
warehouse and killed himself now now
when you hear that story that's a
classic American story that's just a fun
good american tale of life in the
suburbs now when you hear that story you
think about the kid right right would
you think about my kid because i had to
sit down and explain to my kid so far
[ __ ] removed from the ripple right
right how far removed to my my son is
not friends with that kid but my son is
friends with a kid who's friends with
that kid so i just sit down my son and
say hey this is what happened because he
was gonna hear about it from her right
no matter what he's six she's going to
say their daddy's dead and their mommy
and we're reliably mama it's like come
on kids aren't like out of a secret
listened or explore a small chat yes hey
you know doors really funny also the sky
shot my head so I just tell him like
there's something wrong with this guy's
brain and he he killed his wife and we
went through the whole thing and he had
a lot of questions in love LA but people
don't think about the ripple effect so
if somebody goes into school and shoot
17 people right the [ __ ] enormity of
how many people are affected is insane I
think about this all the time in
relation to the fact that a lot of
schools now have metal detectors yeah
and they do drills on what happens
if there's a school [ __ ] it's worse in
la at recess and at lunch the school's
classrooms cannot commingle so if you're
in the fourth grade and you're in mrs.
carex class you cannot play with the
fourth graders from miss Johnson's class
why because of an emergen they have to
be able account for all the kids why
would they do that there's no other
reason earthquakes don't matter like
that nothing matters but if someone
walks in the playground and start
shooting that's why you would do that so
we literally are constructing our
schools around the idea of shootings as
if that's normal and okay and it's
[ __ ] insane I don't want you to have
to go through a metal detector digan oh
oh that's why would you I don't want you
as a child right to have to practice a
drill because there is a possibility
that a shooter will come into the school
and like I just don't I think that's it
it seemed or bear cost that it has for
the rest of the society yeah and this is
what we're told me mental car that we're
all in this together I'm very big on in
the moment on the idea of public spaces
versus private spaces and I think that
we have the balance completely wrong we
seem to apply this general [ __ ]
standard to everyone thinks that public
and private spaces should have almost
the same [ __ ] rules it's ridiculous
here's what the route that I mean here's
what i would suggest the rule should be
that we have to work harder on the way
that we all behave in public spaces and
relax a little about whatever people do
in their own [ __ ] private totally you
know what if you want to smoke in your
house yeah smoke if i can all day long
yeah if you want to smoke next to a
primary school you can't like if their
berries it's a very simple way to look
at the world right don't behave if you
want to stop in your house and read your
[ __ ] phone and walk around the house
do it don't do it in a crowded street
and get in the way of other people
you're not once you're in a public space
we have to have rules that we're all
sharing these public spaces and that we
all have to kind of commingle together
yeah when you're in your own private
space we should relax a little about you
know what people do in yeah that doesn't
hurt anybody right but we seem to have
this like [ __ ] on one approach all fit
all those things where it's a minute
thing the like you said the ripple on
effect that carry on effect of light
easy in our society it's it's the things
that you don't
even because people have shyam had a
problem with you having your gun or your
[ __ ] semi-automatic or what everyone
if there was no negative consequences
but there's tons of neg like this hey
dresses like he it's insane how many
negative consequences they are my love
bringing but if you told me tomorrow if
I stopped eating pringles no kids will
get shot at school today's story came
out there today the biggest police union
in the country said that they wanted
police so the NFL is a ban on guns in
stadiums except for of course uniformed
officers yes fair enough that includes
cops who were just going to the game as
fans and today the cops came out and
said look we need to be able to have all
of our cops with guns whether they're on
duty or not at the stadium because in
case there's a shooter and of course my
responsible we've never had a shooter in
an in a stadium yeah but also I can't
think of anything less that I want then
drunk cops with guns anybody drunk with
guns how about no beer and guns you
can't I don't care how [ __ ] trained
you are you don't get to have a gun and
be sitting there pounding beers all
[ __ ] day right cuz you're gonna shoot
somebody cuz you're drunk right or you
or you maybe you won't shoot someone but
some other drunk idiot next to you cease
your [ __ ] gun and because you're
drunk and your reflexes on how they
normally were they grab you if I can
come and they shoot something or what if
a terrorist actually wants get a gun
into a stadium how hard is it for him to
say I'm from [ __ ] Ohio and here's my
badge I'm a cop there and walk into the
stadium with a gun like oh these your
[ __ ] heads he's what you want if
there's a terrorist event in a crowded
Stadium more guys in civilian truck laws
to holding up his guns yeah like no it's
just it's just our country it's this
it's this crazy brainwash thing and it's
and it's completely manufactured by the
gun manufacturers they've created this
over the past like 25-30 years it's it's
not part of our Constitution it is
wholly manufactured by the gun companies
to sell guns and the way that people
have been braced
is so [ __ ] crazy without they don't
put a thought into it it's just this
knee-jerk I go down my guns and it's
like were you part of a society or are
you not right that's that bow that's
that what it comes down to it yes I and
this is my public versus private spaces
thing which is like when you're in
public you're part of a society yeah
because the roads you drive on to work
and the hospital that you're going to go
to and the school that you send your
kids to or whatever like whatever it is
the taxation system there you know
whatever we do we are generally part of
a society because we've realized as a
species that it is better for us to work
together to move forward than it is to
go out on our own one by one yeah i mean
that's essential here right yeah that
it's all eventually about us progressing
forward you know whatever way but we are
so ever since you know look Margaret
Thatcher and Ronald Reagan put forth the
idea that we are not a society and we've
been running with it ever since as fast
as we can a bit that bit there's a
couple of people listening to this right
now and let [ __ ] a lot better when they
didn't talk about it yeah but I think I
ass has never been as good since days
thought he could say something we should
put that one up we did about climate
change that made us go oh my god right I
eventually erased that it said I'm like
a good instead of my computer for a
couple years where I was like oh maybe
one day I'll just put someone know that
you know what that would have been but
none that would have been the one after
you died in the car wreck and someone
releases that as the the unreleased TOFA
but yeah yeah my mom like 2x mom just
case finding old [ __ ] that are recorded
in my phone and releasing it every four
years hang on is this will anderson
ranting over Bruno Mars Jesus this
why is he so obsessed with ethics in
games journalism yeah all right we
should finish up Dave so I'm going to
put this one up later in the week so
what do you got I'll sit down let me
look it up okay well Jim I plug for you
look at me so my shows my fire at will
show which may be about public and
private spaces and maybe about the
universe or maybe about something else
that I think about I don't know it's day
one of thinking about that it's a blank
slate at this stage but it is on sale in
Adelaide Adelaide Fringe Festival
cameras already sold out adelaide fringe
festival there are tickets on sale
brisbane comedy festival only doing a
week there it always sells out so if you
want to come in brisbane are getting
quick for that one I would recommend
Melbourne Comedy Festival i'm doing the
fewer shows this year and it is selling
faster than ever which is brilliant
thank you so much for supporting it but
if you want to get in for one of the
cheaper nights wednesday and thursday
are the cheaper nights this run so if
you're a fan of a cheaper night i would
recommend you getting for those tickets
because they are going very quickly my
will luminaries show is available no no
it's not anymore because by the time you
hear this it will be off ABC iview for
free so if you did not see it now you
can still buy the DVD afore you saw it
for free on the ABC there is 15 minutes
more on the DVD + an entirely different
show vd gone by that well you know I
spread the word I just really want to
sell enough that I can make another one
next year that's very much my yeah my by
same with that I have another podcast is
called velocity Toph up will be back as
people may know because Charlie posted
on the facebook page but if you have not
heard his mum who was on Toph up his mom
Eileen died she'd been sick for a long
while and so we've just had a little
break we actually have an episode
recorded and we were going to put up the
patreon and a few other things but
because Charlie has been obviously
seeing his mum a lot recently and of all
that stuff we just thought it was best
I'm just going to leave all that until
he's back and ready and has a cool head
space for that and then we'll just put
up those episodes and tell everybody
about that but i'm in denver denver
people i am in denver next week at
comedy works for what
so come and see me hanging out in Denver
that would be cool she going on the road
together I would love to do that though
I mean it would be brilliant if anyone
will actually have us ah oh yeah that's
true I didn't think about that part yeah
I mean like you know I don't but yeah
come and see me in Denver and tell me to
tell them that you'd like Dave Anthony
to come out yeah so let's go blader okay
so ah money the seventh i'm at fringe in
los feliz oh yeah that's fun tuesday a
time at blam-blam-blam- in Koreatown i
don't know i get our bar life
interesting it's kind of fun yeah then
the 12th vancouver we're doing a live
dollop what day of the week is that is a
Saturday night that I not okay nice one
then kuva if you don't chose in
Vancouver but I did the festival once
that's it a long time ago um I imagine
and I hope that there will be there are
certainly be people listening to this
and no people in Vancouver Thank of as a
massive Australian city oh it is yeah
cuz of the ski fields so like when I do
shows in Vancouver like sold out there
was like I was like I did that festival
and I had the show on the opening night
and it was like it was 300 safe room and
I was kind of like is it going to be
anybody at this and I get sold out my I
really and then it was just like [ __ ]
208 larious of course yeah that would be
really 14th of a hot tub here in Los
Angeles not and then so the big
announcement today okay so SF pod fest
January 24th we are doing a live walking
the room okay so you can go to the SF
sketchfest sorry I so pops up sketchfest
website and get those against and it was
just not today on the thirty-first we
are doing a live dollop at LA riot
comedy festival and patent oz will be
our guest and those to get your Swan
sale on the thirty-first 30 first of
January my best thing oh really you
should come down are you gonna be here
where you gonna be all right that's how
are you going back to you and [ __ ]
patent let me give you a cupcake or
whatever happened ok
then I mean um what else was I going to
say and then I am currently I just
started talking with Gareth about coming
back to Australia in July or August Oh
that'd be brilliant i'll run hong kong i
should mention home oh yeah you're going
to Hong Kong yeah I'm the fifth and
sixth of january i believe i will be in
hong kong so have you ever done that
before not never been hong kong pretty
good yeah it'd be fun um and then what
else do I want to say oh and then New
York and Chicago we are also gonna set
that ok firstly it all up alright well
thank you very much Dave let's not to
have you back there's nice to me because
all the world's problems right didn't I
we look the gun thing is over we wrapped
it up I do want to do a signed off i
forget it's been so long that i totally
forgot they used to do so now I'm oh I
mean now that you're more political at
profit yeah I'm Tracy should come with a
message yeah I guess yeah hey it's gonna
be different now the farming episode of
pho pho is testified MA it contains some
coarse language some nudity drug
references a sex scene time travel
terrible Batman impersonations at
Charlie claussen pronounced Clausen
shaped hole and mild coarse language
faux Fuhrer's that the program is not
suitable for persons under the age of 15
and minors must be accompanied by an
adult guardian or priest this is John
dig speaking Bing Bing Bing
digging digging digging digging digging